From pet monkeys, to ice picks and stolen
peaches,
Sarah Paulson's super-stylish Nurse Ratched
has arrived on Netflix taking us on a dark
horror-filled tour of the American psychiatric
care system.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers,
I'm Jan and in this video we're taking a deep
dive into Ratched Season 1,
the ending and the 4-season arc planned for
the series,
plus I'll point out some cool details you
might have missed.
Spoilers ahead, so take care if you haven't
seen the show yet.
In terms of Ratched's brother Edmund, by the
end of the final episode, he and Mildred have
become enemies.
Edmund's botched attempt at escape with Dolly
put him under a stricter lockdown when he
was recaptured,
and with an excruciating death awaiting him
in the electric chair,
Mildred decides to secretly euthanise him
herself.
But when Charlotte Wells, now in her Dr Hanover
persona, breaks him out, he discovers his
sister's plan, which turns him against her.
With no other way out,
obviously Mildred's intention was to stop
him suffering an agonising death in the electric
chair,
but Edmund doesn't see it that way,
even though he himself was to blame for screwing
up their original plan to get him off the
death sentence at the Spring dance.
On top of that, Edmund still seems to blame
Mildred for running when he murdered their
abusive foster parents, even though he told
her to leave.
So when Edmund reveals he massacred seven
nurses in Chicago, Mildred understands he's
coming for her, thus setting him up to be
her primary antagonist in Season 2.
And given that Dolly shot Gwen during her
and Edmund's escape, I think it's possible
that he could try and hurt his sister by targeting
Gwendolyne as well.
If Edmund does end up killing Gwen, this could
be particularly traumatic for Mildred, given
how she helped her accept her sexuality and
learn how to love.
"My feelings for you are the truest thing
in me.
I love you."
Gwen's death might be what sets Mildred off
down an even darker and more repressive path
again,
taking her closer to the cold and hardened
character of Nurse Ratched we see in One Flew
Over The Cuckoo's Nest,
which this series is a prequel to.
As for Edmund's ultimate fate, there could
be a clue in the way the TV show seems to
present some parallels between him and Jack
Nicholson's character Randle in the movie.
For example, in the opening scene of the first
episode,
Edmund wears a leather jacket and green T-shirt
similar to Randle's leather jacket that he
wears when we he arrives at the hospital and
also his green T-shirt.
There's also the way that Edmund tries to
fake that he's insane to make sure that he
doesn't stand trial,
which is similar to how Nicholson's Randle
pretended to be mentally ill in the movie
to get out of doing hard labour in prison.
And by the end of Season 1, Edmund is now
Mildred's primary antagonist, just like Randle
became Nurse Ratched's principal adversary
in the movie.
So, given Mildred tells Edmund, that she's
the one who'll be coming after him,
I wonder whether he'll end up captured by
Mildred and then lobotomised to neutralise
the threat he poses to her,
similar to what happened to Randle in Cuckoo's
Nest,
and ironically similar to how Mildred originally
saved Edmund from the surviving priest's eye-witness
testimony.
And in her eyes, Mildred might even see lobotomising
Edmund as an act of mercy of sorts so that
he can no longer continue his murderous ways.
What's interesting about how the first season
of Ratched ends is the extent to which Mildred
subverts our expectations of her based on
how she was initially depicted in the season's
early episodes.
In Mildred's opening scene in the Pilot,
we get a sense of her brooding darkness and
inner repression as she watches a couple engaged
in heavy PDA,
then proceeds to scold a distracted gas attendant
about his filthy fingernails.
We then watch her lie her way into a nurse's
position at Lucia State Hospital where she
encourages a patient's suicide which she then
helps Dr Hanover cover up.
Using this as leverage, she has him make her
head nurse, taking over from Nurse Bucket.
And there's an interesting detail which foreshadows
the way Mildred quickly insinuates herself
into this position of power when Bucket brings
some lilies of the valley into Hanover's office.
The lily of the valley is a species of flower
that spreads aggressively and which is toxic,
sometimes lethal.
Already by the second episode, we see how
Mildred is excited to observe Dr Hanover's
demonstration of the lobotomy procedure on
four newly arrived patients,
and with her passive-aggressive threats against
anyone who wrongs her,
it sets us up to assume she'll be travelling
down a progressively darker path as the season
goes on.
"What are you gonna do about it?
What are you, deaf?"
"No.
I'm just thinking of all the things I'm going
to do about it."
Which is why it feels surprising when Mildred
turns compassionate towards Betsy after she's
rejected by Dr Hanover at the Spring dance.
Despite the evidence of a more human side,
Mildred clearly has this dark underbelly and
admits to Gwen that she holds no regrets for
everything she's done.
"The lies I told to get into that hospital,
to get closer to Edmund...
Those were amoral acts, and I understand that
completely, but you must understand that I
had no choice.
And if I had to, I would do it all over again."
Speaking to Vanity Fair, Sarah Paulson said
that she identifies "very deeply with [Mildred's]
loneliness"
and thinks that what drives her character
is "a pursuit of survival and of finding some
sense of home.
[It's] sort of an animal need that blinds
her to the inappropriateness of some her actions."
A character who we may see return in the second
season is the odious Henry,
the son of Miss Osgood who according to his
mother's will finds himself disinherited and
destined to be sent to a psychiatric institution
at the end of Season 1.
It's not hard to think that he'll probably
end up at Lucia State Hospital,
where he might try to manipulate any of the
nurses looking after him,
similar to how he had his mother brutally
killed by one of his servants.
And if Henry discovers it was Mildred who
was paid a large bounty from his mother in
return for Dr Hanover's head,
then he might try and blackmail her;
though I can't imagine the outcome would be
favourable for him if he gets on her bad side.
By the way, there was an intriguing detail
I noticed in the scene when Mildred presents
Miss Osgood with Dr Hanover's head.
The painting that's positioned perfectly between
the two women is Salome with the decapitated
head of John the Baptist.
Like Miss Osgood, who requested Dr Hanover's
head as revenge for his part in her son losing
his limbs, in the Bible Salome requested the
head of John be brought to her as vengeance
on behalf of her mother.
Another way that Mildred rationalises both
her good and bad actions is through the idea
that she's an "angel of mercy".
This theme first came up in the pilot episode:
"I admire nurses more than anything.
They really are God's angels."
"Yes.
Yes, we are."
This is developed further in the two "Angel
of Mercy" episodes where Huck calls Mildred
by that name after she helps two patients
escape so they no longer have to undergo the
cruel hydrotherapy treatments,
a form of conversion therapy designed to supposedly
eradicate their lesbianism.
"You're an angel.
What you did for those women.
Mildred Ratched...
you're an angel of mercy."
Then there are the flashbacks to Ratched's
time as a nurse during the war, when she would
frequently euthanise severely wounded soldiers
who asked her to put them out of their misery.
The term "angel of mercy" also has multiple
layers of meaning.
It's sometimes used as a nickname for nurses
in general, with Florence Nightingale being
one of the first nurses who was dubbed an
"angel of mercy".
And then there's the criminological use of
the term,
where it refers to serial killers,
frequently caregivers who decide to kill their
patients whether it be for compassionate or
sadistic reasons rather than treat them.
I also noticed the artwork on the Netflix
page for Ratched has Rorschach-test inkblots
positioned behind Mildred that give the impression
of angel wings emerging from behind her.
Ratched also perceives herself as an angel
of mercy, believing that she's helping some
of her victims find peace from their suffering.
"You have been subjected to enough pain.
You deserve someone to show you mercy, Mr.
Salvatore."
Engineering Salvatore's suicide was, of course,
self-serving for Mildred, but an even more
shocking example of how she can quickly switch
between compassion and brutality is in the
fourth episode.
In the course of one evening,
Mildred helps Ingrid and Lily escape their
shockingly painful hydrotherapy treatments,
but at the same time with the help of Dr Hanover,
she locks Charles Wainwright into one of the
tanks and turns the temperature up to a level
that will boil him alive.
Getting rid of Charles is not only expedient
as it's yet another death on the hospital
premises that Mildred can hold over Hanover,
but it's also a form of revenge for the poor
way Charles treated her.
The series really whipsaws us in the way we
often simultaneously see cruelty and kindness
in Mildred.
At the same time that she and Betsy conspire
to turn Dr Hanover in to the authorities,
she kindly asks Bucket to make Huck head nurse,
because she knew he was suffering from a feeling
of lack of purpose in his life.
The reveal of her dreadful childhood also
makes her more sympathetic.
Mildred is most definitely a complicated but
intriguing character and Gwendolyne expresses
how she and perhaps many viewers may feel
about her when she says:
"I don't understand how I got so...
tangled up in you."
That's also a nice reference to the opening
title sequence for the series in which we
see characters chasing and pulling on a tangled
red string that leads to Nurse Ratched.
Something that's also a major theme in the
first season of Ratched is the idea of image,
façade, and fantasy;
in particular our protagonist Mildred who
presents herself as the image of a perfect
nurse while also dressed to the nines.
However, this is a false image or façade
as Mildred never trained as a nurse and lied
her way into the army,
falsified her interview letter with Dr Hanover,
her clothes are stolen,
and despite her lesbian fantasies, she tries
to repress these feelings by having sex with
Charles Wainwright and uses roleplays to get
through this.
There's also the hospital itself which is
decked out like a luxury hotel despite being
financially on the brink of closing down.
Numerous other characters also live in their
own fantasy worlds.
Dolly sees herself as a kind of movie star
and romanticises her escape with serial killer
Edmund.
"This is killer-diller good luck.
Like Bonnie and Clyde."
This fantasy leads to a tragic end for her
though, because similar to Bonny and Clyde,
Dolly gets herself killed when the pair are
discovered by the police.
Betsy Bucket also has a misguided belief or
fantasy that Dr Hanover actually cares for
her, when in reality he can't stand her.
And he himself is living a double-life, hiding
from his past and his disaster with Miss Osgood's
son Henry.
Tragically, and perhaps ironically,
Dr Hanover ends up killed by his patient Charlotte
Wells when her psyche breaks and she takes
on one of her fantasy personas,
believing Hanover to be Adolf Hitler.
That personality is based on Jesse Owens,
the African American athlete who won four
gold medals at the 1936 Berlin Olympic Games
in Nazi Germany.
In contrast to the others living in a fantasy,
the main character who deals with things in
a much more straightforward way is Huck.
Huck is damaged too, but his character's wounds
are more external rather than internalised
like many of the others.
And for me, I was gutted when he was killed
as he felt like one of the only truly decent
characters in the show.
If you're wondering about how long Ratched
will run for, well, Ryan Murphy apparently
has four seasons mapped out, each one featuring
a different male adversary for Mildred.
For Season 1, this was Dr Hanover, and it
looks like Edmund will be her main antagonist
in the second season.
Sarah Paulson has also said that by the fourth
season she expects the show to be in the events
of One Flew Over The Cuckoo's Nest, so that
could mean we'll see Randle McMurphy show
up to oppose Mildred.
I expect if that happens, there will a few
changes to the story from the film, in a similar
way to how Bates Motel modified some of the
events from Psycho in its final season.
So, what did you think about the first season
of Ratched?
And do you have any predictions or things
you'd like to see in the second season?
Leave your thoughts in the comments below.
If you enjoyed this, don't forget to leave
a thumbs-up and subscribe for all my upcoming
videos.
Tap left for my next Netflix video or tap
right for something else you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!